all right take a look at your screen
right there across China authorities are
now going all in on crippling covet
lockdowns and unleashing massive human
rights violations against innocent
citizens as residents now are literally
being locked into their own homes and
apartments unable to leave all facing
severe punishment and prosecution if
they dare to question any of this sadly
it appears to only be getting worse and
as a new warning from the U.S embassy is
suggesting that lockdowns are about to
intensify but many Brave Chinese
citizens they are standing up for their
freedom they are refusing to comply with
the never ending covet lockdown Madness
that is gripping China but the Biden
Administration they seem to have no
reaction at all whatsoever why is that
why don't they stand in solidarity with
people that believe in Freedom take a
look
what is the president's reaction when he
hears protesters in China chant Freedom
or Xi Jinping step down the president's
not going to speak for protesters around
the world they're speaking for
themselves
and so there's no reaction these
protesters are speaking for themselves
what we are doing is making it clear
that we support the right of peaceful
protest does the White House support
their effort to sort of regain
personal freedoms in light of these
lockdowns the White House supports the
right of peaceful protest
maybe just maybe China has the Biden
family compromised you know the 1.5
billion dollar deal with the Bank of
China the 5 million dollar no interest
rate for givable loan I wish I got that
deal uh or the hundred thousand dollar
shopping spree for Hunter and his family
hmm I don't know Deutsche Bank Goldman
Sachs uh JP Morgan no I'll go with
Hunter Biden the crack guy Heroes
reaction former white house chief of
staff reince priebus along with author
of The Coming collapse of China China a
senior fellow at the Gatestone Institute
Gordon Chang is back with us Ryan so
let's get your take first on this why
why not even a word of solidarity to me
everything goes back everything is
suspect as it relates to China Russia
Kazakhstan Ukraine and other countries
where the bidens made money now why
wouldn't they stand in solidarity for
the people of China to to freely Express
their view uh and stand up against what
is obvious tyranny and a Crackdown
against innocent people
I'm with you Sean I this weakness this
theme of weakness that she keeps popping
up at Joe Biden just doesn't go away and
starting with Afghanistan then you know
it started obviously with inflation at
home then Afghanistan and it continues
through Iran through Russia now China
and honestly it's it's it's it's even
baffling to me uh because you know I do
events all over the country a lot of
times with Democrats and I find that one
of the only things that we can agree on
is China and Taiwan and the fact that he
once again sides with this this this
side of weakness which you know when
Ronald Reagan coined the phrase peace
through strength the other side of that
sentence is that weakness invites
aggression and these people have been
locked down in some cases since August
8th they're holding blank sheets of
paper up because it's symbolizing the
fact that they've got no voice we've got
a president in the White House who at
one time when it came to protesting our
police officers said that the protests
that took place in the United States
that were burning down buildings and
police precincts were in his words were
right and necessary and when it comes to
China he says nothing what he should say
is that we condemn the CCP we we and we
stand up for these protesters who are
standing up for Freedom the this China
and and your and and Stephen knows as
good as anybody that China isn't just
looking to win a battle with the Western
World they're they're wanting the
Western World to melt down and
completely go away in a practical
overthrow of the West and so the fact
that we've got a president who won't at
least stand up and be strong at a time
when it makes total and complete sense
even through probably most people in his
own party is completely baffling you
know Gordon the last time I I can think
of anything similar was Tiananmen Square
and and I think most people remember
that iconic image of the sky standing in
front of a tank and the tank would move
and he'd move in front of the tank and
the tank would move again to get around
and move back in the other direction so
this is very unusual for China but
they're also calling for president XI to
step down that's not something I
expected to see now it's fascinating to
me because for two years I've been
warning about this new access of Eva
which is a relationship with Russia and
China and Iran and all three of these
countries now are experiencing unrest at
the same time now is it possible I don't
think you win revolutions with
slingshots but is it possible president
XI has to worry about his regime
I think he certainly does because the
protesters on the Chinese streets over
the weekend were not only saying that Xi
Jinping must step down they were saying
that the Communist party has to leave
China because the Chinese people want to
govern themselves and that is
revolutionary and right now the
Communist party is rounding up people
because China has maybe 620 million
surveillance cameras it has artificial
intelligence spatial recognition which
by the way they got from Microsoft and
others and they can identify all of
these people you know it is the number
one job of American president to clearly
and proudly defend and promote freedom
and democracy and we didn't hear that
from John Kirby we didn't hear it from
President Biden's statement shame on us
because these are our values and when we
don't promote our values the Chinese
notice
you know the thing that that I would
like to see just to vote of solidarity
just a vote of support but you know
Ryan's it always comes down to one thing
with me and the and the bidens
why would China give a 1.5 billion
dollar deal to Hunter Biden and his
associates with zero experience rather
than Deutsche Bank Goldman Sachs you
pick whatever big financial institution
you want why would they do that unless
of course they have the Biden family
compromised which you have to look at in
any one of these deals don't you
well you have to and I think that I
think that Congressman Comer is going to
do that and I think that this issue is
going to be front and center very
quickly and and Joe Biden needs to
answer these questions but the other
thing about all this is this odd and
baffling silence is maybe it come it
strikes too close to home for the
Democrats because they're the ones that
want to close Schools they're the ones
that want people to be in Mass forever
they're the ones that are in a constant
covet hysteria this is what they're all
about and this is hitting too close to
home for them it makes no sense and to
the businesses out there I mean the fact
that other than Joe Biden mainstream
Republicans and mainstream Democrats
agree on this China issue my advice that
you and business out there if you're
investing in China if you have offices
in China get out because this is the one
thing that I think could could unify the
United States which is a very strong
position against China which makes Joe
Biden's position here completely and
totally out of the mainstream well as
Comer said or congressman Homer said
this is an investigation into the
president of the United States so we'll
see reince thank you Gordon Chang thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else